okay so here we are season two eating
your feet season two season two
I'm Andrew I'm Nikki and this is Patrick
so today our dear dear friends and Annie
challenged us to make OG besan a viral
video we found on YouTube dude it so
this video comes from a channel called
only in Japan this guy John dog makes it
this is a street food shop in Japan
they've got two guys oh there's swinging
swinging mallets I feel like a bowl
looking thing so this is the process of
taking rice to mochi which is this
glutinous rice substance we can't do
that that was really heavy he looked
like he was really like yeah so we're
gonna bring on our culinary expert and
good friend yeah hey Rhea come on down
we're making mochi yay what do you think
it's fun yeah I used to do it when I was
in elementary school I want I asked my
mom to get
I've never had mochi so I'm very excited
Wow in addition to the special equipment
we also needed special rice which we
bought in advance because it needs to be
soaked overnight but what we also bought
is some mochi to eat right now
oh the texture is amazing the outside
green stuff is the mochi inside is red
bean paste and then it's covered in
soybean flour so the texture is very
gelatinous almost like very soft gummy
bears so this way of making mochi
requires those special equipment things
there it's a machine that makes mochi
but they still try to show it this
organization called Kizuna they actually
have this equipment because they do
mochi making classes so they're gonna
lend it to us off to the J ACCC so to
make mochi we are required to find some
special equipment and you have that
special equipment hi who are you and why
do you have this my name is Kent Mata
May and I work here at the Japanese
American culture and community center so
right now we're here in the james irvine
japanese garden in little tokyo and
we're going to be borrowing q zena's
machi suki equipment and Kizer knows
mission is to educate engage and empower
the next generation of Japanese and
Japanese American youth so in order to
make the mochi the traditional way
you're gonna need a few items one year
need a steamer to steam the mochi
gourmet rice and you're going to put it
in the suit and then once it's in there
you're gonna take the kena and you're
going to start breaking down the rice
from its green structure to basically a
paste
I'm gonna take my left hand and make a
fist on top and we're gonna push down
into the blue foo like this
how long does the counting process
typically take depends how much effort
you put into it so for your team for
example we can we can get through one
one she maybe 10 15 minutes oh yeah do
you think we can do this yeah you folks
are gonna be great Wow
I got the Kent seal of approval there do
you know the number of people who die
every year
it's been reduced when eating the mochi
I would say be very careful to chew it
very well people who eat mochi intended
to get choked on it and some people even
die eating it making yes well thank you
for giving us a little lesson of course
I think it's time for us to give it a go
all right look we'll just take like this
okay be careful thank you yeah that's
good
you look like Paul Bunyan all right okay
so to make mochi you start with rice and
we have to get a particular kind of rice
that is meant for mochi making which is
a sweet mochi rice it's superior short
grain sweet rice and now we need to cook
it tent recommended one cup rice to one
and a quarter cups water I think we
should do for yeah four cups of rice has
5 cups of water
[Music]
now I'm measuring the water to rice
ratio beep 60 minutes I could just do
double duty on how light didn't come on
is that so here we are we got it clean
it first I'll scrub it look like a face
yeah yeah we put two eyes right there
it's important that mochi stays hot
while it's being made so we're using
warm water and hopes of warming up the
booths ooh all together yeah oh yeah
this is incredible all right guys good
luck Oh
should we test the texture of it that's
a lot of water
that looks pretty gelatinous they say
it's probably all about and I feel like
even we pound it that's it it's just not
turning to mush we can try it but my
guts telling me my be about it I don't
know guys I'm kind of into it yeah I
hope this work I mean I've never seen
this done okay I have all the rice mail
oh here it comes
more the mallets will help keep it hot
because we'll be dipping it in hot water
and the first thing we're doing is
squidging what's it feel like
oh it's so smushy now looks like mashed
potatoes how's it look great
man it looks like two wooden horses are
like trying to like give each other I
mean it's okay yeah this isn't gonna get
gelatinous and bouncy I don't think this
is gonna get there it's definitely
pacing up but I get why we would want to
just actually start it the right way
from the start do you remember the video
he was clean like it's not coming out
like this it needs to be stickier which
means less water yeah I mean it tastes
like bland dry rice porridge so
yesterday we had some overnight soaked
rice that we put in a rice cooker but we
think that's wrong we think you only
soak if you're going to steam and what
is the difference between cooking and
steaming the mechanism the mechanism so
my wok wife dough meets mom laughs
borrow steamer your work wife
mother-in-law
yeah yeah yeah hello Chet that looks
decided that we're going to steam rice
instead of using the rice cooker I can
do that job I can do that job bottom
it's a park so we feel weeds water and
lay boil we've got eight cups soaked and
do four cups per batch I got mugs for
coffee
thank you I came at the wrong time and
then we spread these cheesecloth over
the steam iron so you just have to poke
the hole so the steam can escape
hmm all right let's stop at this puppy
on let it steam for 30 to 40 minutes and
we will see if we truly could speak here
steam
who wants some I feel pretty good about
our steamer we had this classic method
but we weren't pairing it with the
classic method of steaming it we're
trying to go to high tech with that
robot all right we're doing it this
looks good
oh yeah no it doesn't look like porridge
no yeah that looks like right this is
yeah this is different it's less sloshy
it's it's mushroom yeah it's way more
encouraging yeah let us know when you
want to swap get in there it's harder to
press now cuz it's oh yeah yesterday oh
yeah look at that weight getting there
yeah it definitely looks pretty paced
like yeah imagine making this in an
apartment with your neighbor's house a
ball it up oh good it's more satisfying
than the squishing yeah Adams dying oh
yeah oh gee I'm doing the pounding that
I like oh that pulls pretty nicely yeah
yeah the last round of pound is with
like one person with their hands in
there flipping it and slapping it while
one person pounds we're gonna do that
you're doing great no you guys are too
dangerous we beat the posit now we're
gonna cover it with some warm towels to
keep it hot so we're gonna shape the
mochi and this is much colder rice flour
it's a little when you're shaping make
sure you're covered with your hand weeds
flour perfect
this was actually my first job when I
was 14 just for new year it feels really
good yeah I'm definitely thinking about
like choking and dying now pretty like a
lot yeah I've been thinking about that
all night flower hits the board and you
stick to your hands that oh you got a
cute little yeah you did good so I think
we can eat it right now if you want to
yeah I want to eat it fresh oh yeah made
mochi yeah we did looking at the video
we have not made it green or filled it
with anything which should be our next
stage of the challenge I don't think we
can get this exact ingredient that makes
it green from your video the green is
coming from real mochi it's Japanese
hard I've never seen that anyway so
maybe we can go to a grocery store on
something close to your monkey first
we're gonna sample it with soy sauce
though it's popular way to emoji easily
soy sauce and sugar a little bit sugar
yeah and seaweed yeah yeah I'm getting
right in there
oh yeah that's really satisfying as a
person who only ever had ice cream mochi
yes
flavor is a revelation
[Music]
we're back from the grocery store
sweet bean roasted soybean powder my
giant spittle yomogi
is this gonna make the King a green you
should be alright we just have to be
careful we're about ready to make the
next batch of mochi all right first
things first we got steaming rice Bravo
let's poke holes I think we just steamed
it the same way okay now we're gonna get
the beans ready to go can I tell you
that this is one of my favorite things
to do open cans yeah that's weird
all right so we're going to mash up some
of these beans to be more of a paste can
I ask a question about this bowl is it
used for any specific thing yeah we use
a full ground sesame it's so it's a
sesame baseball are you getting it's
cool something else too yeah can you
guys take that over there create come
here
I want that was my part doing our mochi
dance Junor mochi stance who are our
first Swisher's you want to be the first
mushers yeah so we got to put it in and
fold it through this journey I've felt a
real team a ship with you guys I think
we could pound it for like 10 percent
more get as nice smoother consistency
one must look like a sulfide yeah that
looks way greener Oh see this is
synchronicity this is what sting was
talking about yes that looks great very
slimy looking oh hell yeah ei you know
it really is starting to look a lot like
the video yeah get in there Pat you got
a pal ha ha you know making that sounds
really helps it does I think it's bad
all right we're moving on to the next
phase of slapping pal
[Laughter]
give us the final slap
[Music]
flower
[Music]
oh my god so you're going to take a
portion all right I'm going in the Sui
Dean oh yeah that's that's a no-go you
guys are doing a good job yeah are you
doing Oh bingo Bongo I got it it's just
my champion success we made no cheese we
really did we have a green mochi is
flavored with matcha filled with red
bean paste and covered in a soy bean
powder the signs of learning as well
[Applause]
the red beam really works so well I'm
not very funny yeah the thickest row is
it's better than that first trying lot
smoother after we switched to the
steamer all the methods that we did were
as it would have been done way back in
the history if you could not for tunity
to do this with bikini and the osoo and
a bunch of people do it
maybe she invite a bunch of her friends
see these now yeah it's a good texture
yeah this whole process was made
possible because of Kent and Kizuna and
the Japanese American cultural and
community center big thanks to them and
he told me his mom and he told me oh yes